uh does that look like a problem to you
there she's the mother of all asteroids
screaming towards us dear mind this
summer we're facing extinction partner
worse
this tablet holds the key we go to that
crash site search for cosmic clues and
then figure out how to stop it
who's dumb enough to think they can stop
an asteroid crashing Annie reporting for
duty duty the end of the Ice Age while
you run for your lives will be high in
the sky safe as those birdies lucky shot
no boy he's just the beginning what is
this place idea of a new way the secret
to saving the world is here genuine ama
can you help yes but first down my dog
funky chicken jiggy jelly mouseketool
could you help me please
my nose is dangerously close to my butt
hmm from 20th Century Fox and blue sky
studios okay let's do it
these are the guys who were gonna save
the world we look so cool like a ninja
oh it no suck it was a strategy the
defining chapter kept superpowers
the greatest chilla G of all time you're
the wind beneath my sleeve
the LG of my I I'm getting butterflies
I'm getting nauseous my metals Wow it's
never gonna work hold on to your butts
we're gonna stop this thing about of
eight motherfu forget I said boom ice
age collision course I wanted his true
love everybody has somebody and all I've
got is my boyish good looks miss
mariachi band